well the raiders are family and moving
to las vegas will only benefit our city
the silver and black have a strong
alumni
and they enjoy sharing their wisdom with
our youth one of those former writers
was hanging out with a bunch of kids
from southern nevada
kevin martin has that story i'm just not
a fan of
taking money for a kid's dream pro
football hall of famer and former raider
rod woodson
came out to faith lutheran high school
on saturday morning
where usa football was hosting its
summer blitz youth football clinic
for free you know i want to help the kid
and you know i can't
i can't spend my own money doing all of
it but i don't want to
take all their money and i think it's
critical for
organizations like usa football to come
along to do everything for free
for the communities las vegas was one of
10 stops across the country the usa
football is making this summer where
they are hosting these free clinics
and while of course they are intended to
benefit the local youth as rod woodson
explains these events are also critical
for the coaches you know my main
message to the coaches that they're more
than just coaches
you know i'm one year i mean i remember
being nine years of my
my youth coach and i are great friends i
talk to them all the time i talk to them
yesterday
i mean so you can be a huge influence on
these kids for the rest of their lives
and as the raiders enter their second
season here in vegas
ron points out how beneficial it is for
these youth to have a chance to grow up
in an nfl market
you know when i was in indiana we didn't
have the coals they were in baltimore
right so you know we didn't have that we
only had three channels
so i think live growing up in a market
where you see
pro players proteins is going to be
critical
for and it's really just planting seeds
because you plant a seed somebody else
comes around waters it and that's really
what
life's about it's about planting seeds
to young people
and it's going to be very fun to see our
raiders
especially our current raiders come out
into the community and be a part
of with the with the youth football from
here on out
kevin martin 8 sports now